what's wrong I'm just dealing with some
stuff right now what kind of stuff
anxiety rejection theory already
paralysis character issues morale issues
you know life stuff Charlie one big
state white cooking competition a couple
years valium
look it's a genius in the kitchen are
you go to Brookes morning
I've always gonna be there great yeah I
can explain everyone individually but I
still have it all when they're about to
run their own company what happened with
that call from the coffee shop you can
make this happen you Charlie Rutter
that's the problem
[Music]
listen I was just wanted to tell you
that I I see you all the time a nice
okay get it worse
not really
hi I just wanted to say hello
after what happened back there so how
could we work in a movie theater instead
of a restaurant well you know think I
see what's happening all around me I'm
terrified that I'm so content and
terrified that I'm so not
I can't let feel failure run your life
[Music]
who you talk to me I don't have all the
answers you I don't get you I mean
you're smart you're nice and you're
funny enough sorry oh maybe not on
purpose
[Music]
sometimes no matter how hard it is you
just got a step to the plate sounds like
a bad t-shirt you know it's funny she's
the only girl I have really felt
charming around that's right yeah I'm
just trying to concentrate on giving
myself an aneurysm you're not you me
that's the thing no no
you
[Music]
you